BlackRock Fidelity and Arc invest
recently all filed for Bitcoin spot ETFs
and the entire Market celebrated Bitcoin
exploded higher going 20 right off the
back of those announcements but now the
headlines are saying something different
we saw last week that the SEC asked for
clarification they said we don't have
enough information to actually evaluate
these applications but the problem is
that the mainstream media ran with the
narrative they made it seem like the
ETFs were actually being rejected like
for some reason BlackRock was going to
get handed an L that's not true yet and
so I just went on CNBC to go ahead and
explain the nuances here and describe
exactly why Bitcoin is up 85 to start
the year here's that appearance the SEC
saying applications for spot Bitcoin
ETFs are inadequate
according to the Wall Street Journal the
agency informed the NASDAQ and the CBOE
that BlackRock and Fidelity's proposals
are insufficient
the news sending the price of Bitcoin
down on Friday it says here I don't know
join us it doesn't look like you're
there join us now is Anthony pompliano
founder of pomp Investments if it was
down on Friday it didn't last long
because that's a that's a yearly high at
least a year to date High where it is
right now thirty thousand six hundred
isn't it Anthony
it's pretty close to it Joe yeah um
there are times when I feel inadequate I
don't know about you Anthony but it's a
it's a very sort of uh diffuse not a not
a real specific feeling because that's
what I feel like the SEC what the heck
what is inadequate BlackRock infidelity
don't know how to do an application for
a spot what about it is inadequate pump
and and would they rather have FTX and
binance and all these other exchanges
involved instead of something as simple
as the underlying asset itself in a spot
ETF they just don't like Bitcoin that
that's all there is to it
yeah I think we have to separate out
kind of the historical Trends and kind
of conversation from this specific issue
and so really what the SEC is saying
here is hey all of you put for these
applications there's a specific detail
around a surveillance sharing agreement
uh that's unclear who are you going to
be working with so you say in the
application you're working with someone
who is it
um and so they're not rejecting the
applications they're not saying hey
these are not going to get approved what
they're simply saying is give us the
full information we want to understand
it and so uh already we've seen CBOE go
ahead and refile uh clarifying that
those surveillance sharing agreements
will be with coinbase my expectation is
that we'll see NASDAQ on the BlackRock
ETF do the exact same thing early this
week and so really this is a lot of
hoopla and a lot of you know
conversation but at the end of the day I
think it's a very small detail that
probably is much more a formality than
anything else and it leads to look
Bitcoin is up 85 to start the years the
best performing asset and uh kind of the
first half of the year and I think that
what we're watching is Wall Street
saying we want access to this thing and
they're knocking on the door now and so
the SEC he's gonna have to make some
decisions as to which applications they
want to improve and how they're going to
allow them to go ahead and get exposure
uh the what I found interesting about
what you just said is that you think
it's just a formality and it's going to
happen because I don't know whether
that's true uh if it is fine but so what
if they come back and and still don't
because they've seen like they haven't
wanted
to let this happen do you think it's
fundamentally different now because it's
BlackRock uh and and Fidelity and some
big names so you think it's just a
matter of time and it's a formality so
it's going to happen that's going to be
huge if it happened
well look I you know again I don't have
a crystal ball I don't think anyone does
but blackrock's got a 575 to one record
in terms of these ETF applications and
so whenever you see something like that
it is Blackrock Etc they probably have a
very high degree of confidence that this
is going to get approved now does that
mean it's going to get approved next
week or in a year I'm not sure but I
think that most people have confidence
that a Bitcoin spot ETF will be approved
at some point and the real question is
once that happens how big will it get
right we saw the Futures ETF had about a
billion dollars of inflow in the first
week and so if a spot ETF gets approved
well we see a billion dollars in a
single day it seems pretty crazy to me
that we've gotten this far 600 billion
dollars uh in the Bitcoin asset without
a spot ETF in the United States and so
when it happens I do think that a lot of
people will pour Capital into it and
there's just too many people who want
exposure to this product for us to never
get it
you never know that that could be it
could some things top out when when you
know it's bought on the rumor and so on
the news but
Bitcoin has has held up I mean 85 as you
point out at the same time that all
these headlines were hitting about SBS
sandbagments read about all you know CZ
all these things were hitting and it
almost as was as if yeah those are
ancillary we're talking about the asset
itself we're not talking about the
people handling the asset it's almost
like it's strengthened I mean 85 but
it's still down from 65 000 as people
point out
of course and I think that you know
Bitcoin is anti-fragile right and the
reason why that's important is if you
look at the start of the Year nasdaq's
up about 32 it's the fastest start in
the first six months of a year uh since
about 1983. Bitcoin is up almost triple
that and so to talk about the
performance of this asset to be up you
know 85 and it almost seems like no
one's paying attention yes it is down
still but I think that what we have to
realize is that the underlying
fundamentals of Bitcoin continue to
strengthen as well we see hash rate
hitting all-time highs we see adoption
hitting all-time highs we continue to
see all of these different data points
that we know feed into the price leading
into the having that's going to occur
next year and so again you know we've
talked about it on this program for
years now that Bitcoin as an asset it's
not controlled by anyone there are
millions and millions of people around
the world that continue to adopt it the
public narrative sometimes is bullish
sometimes it's bearish there's greed and
there's fear but ultimately Bitcoin
continues to do exactly what it's
designed to do it produces block after
block after block of transactions anyone
in the world with internet connection
can go ahead and use it and therefore
we're watching around the world people
are realizing the value of that and
they're putting uh all sorts of capital
into the network and we're watching the
performance kind of follow Melissa Lee
was doing crypto before anybody was
doing it on her show or would you say
you've been ignoring we had a Bitcoin
bug
have you done much on it lately lately
we do it when there's Milestones yeah
for sure it's not like you know maybe
once a week right but uh Hey YouTube
both have done a great job before you go
I'm curious you know let's say Gary
Gensler resigns which was the rumor
circulating around the internet you know
thanks to AI over the weekend does the
crypto trade go higher is it is it as
easy as that or or no
yeah I saw the rumor I have no clue you
know whenever I see Anonymous sources
and coming from kind of pseudonymous
accounts on Twitter I always uh I pay
attention but I also you know take with
a grain of salt
um I I do think that there's probably uh
some sort of short-term impact in prices
but over the long term I don't think who
the regulator is is going to matter
nearly as much uh you know take the
Bitcoin ETF as an example uh there was
Regulators before Gary ginsler it wasn't
approved then either
um and so I tend to think that we put a
lot of uh time and effort focused on
individuals but at the end of the day
this is a technology Trend that uh in
the short term you know it can be
resisted there can be friction but I do
think over the long term uh it's pretty
obvious that this is something people
want and ultimately I think the people
will get it
that's what we're going to be watching
for then so I I thought those were
excuses so there were some specific
things they're asking for about
surveillance that are easily answered
and then they won't you say they won't
have an excuse at that point to not go
forward with it that's your viewpoint
look they can come up with all kinds of
different reasons why they don't want it
I think on this yeah I think on this
specific reason the surveillance sharing
agreement you know CBOE again it came
out late last week they already refiled
for a number of these I think it was
Wisdom Tree Invesco Fidelity Etc and so
my guess is that they could come up with
something else but this specific thing
is not going to be a big deal okay pom
Anthony pompliano thank you
all right thanks guys to be watching